ça fait du bien
ça serait trop pas comment il m'a
regardé king
kong à la réalité d'organiser des
tournois avec lascars ne connaissez
mieux on les connaissait bien
[Musique]
nous avons jour quand on passait en
bagnole si je te faut les jeux trouvera
une molette ou je trouve pas la face
avec aso
je peux entrer dans la police pour
techique de merde à west les rentrées
pourquoi raconte ça m'intéresse tu leur
donnes un flingue à gaza s'est
vu aujourd'hui
c'est la police madame
n'est pas des assistantes sociales je ne
peux plus tous et croate je bosse de
nuit à 200 bornes de chez moi je vois
jamais mon mari et mon fils les bottes
de film passera rien
les gens ils sont tellement line que
c'est un nom qui s'en prennent ça va
tous nous péter à la gueule
tu crois que vous voit pas emmerdé dit
oui les petits les petites car tu vois
vous en bavez des fois donné le coup
petit quelque chose
on a dit tenir le coup